sí Qué representa este día sigue
teniendo ese mismo significado que
adquirió a sus inicios hace más de 50
años
creemos que el significado tiene que ver
sí con con la lucha con la resistencia
con la protesta con la reivindicación y
sobre todas las cosas con no solamente
con la celebración no de poder ver
quiénes somos y sentir orgullo por ello
sino también poder promover y poder
reconocer en nuestra lucha en nuestra
militancia un proyecto y una y una
iniciativa de amor de inclusión de
diversidad el que rompa con el paradigma
de la discriminación del odio de los
crímenes de de toda aquellas
iniciativas que promueven justamente la
no inclusión y el el no derecho para que
esas personas que vivimos nuestra
sexualidad de forma libre Autónoma e
independiente no entonces creo que que
por supuesto han cambiado muchas cosas
pero otras no y por eso el significado
no solamente es celebrar Yo también
protestar sino también promover
justamente en un mundo que
lamentablemente está en un contexto muy
difícil no de de guerra de odio de
antiderechos es un momento crucial para
escuchar las voces que quieres por
ejemplo nosotros desde el movimiento
eléctrico más estamos trabajando para
más democracia más igualdad y más
respeto Y a propósito de los Derechos
Cuáles hoy el panorama para la comunidad
lgbtiq en América Latina
bueno el panorama es es bastante también
complejo y diverso en nuestro país y
nuestro nuestras regiones muy diversas
creemos que estamos a la vanguardia en
muchos aspectos no en nuestro país
tenemos el matrimonio igualitario la ley
de identidad de género leyes de
vanguardia a nivel internacional pero
también en muchos otros países aún hoy
todavía seguimos teniendo el peligro de
caminar libremente por las calles existe
una gran campaña contra las niñeses y
contra las personas adultas mayores
contra las personas tal vez y trans el
la comunidad del colectivo travesti
trans es uno de los colectivos más
excluidos y discriminados por la
sociedad y por los estados y creemos que
justamente una de las una de las
cuestiones más importantes que debemos
trabajar en todo el mundo es terminar
con la criminalización y trabajar por
una educación inclusiva y por una
democracia Que respete e incluya a todos